and joining us from New York Amy Goodman
who is the host of Pacifica radios
Democracy Now program on radio and on
television and on the Internet have we
covered all mediums yet but we're
working on many more Steve it's good to
be with you and also the author of a
book with your brother what was that all
about well my brother David Goodman is
also a journalist and so we both are
very involved with looking directly at
the media and wrote the book the
exception to the rulers exposing oily
politicians war profiteers and the media
that love them I want to begin by
getting your reaction to President Bush
when he met with reporters this past
week to the White House indicating that
it will be the decision of the next
president to decide how long troops stay
in Iraq what did you think well I think
it's difficult to get the truth out of
the bush administration but in this case
we did in this case President Bush was
quite clear he said it's up to future
presidents so we're talking what 2009 I
ultimately think there is a force more
powerful than the President of the
United States and that is the American
people and that it's up to them to
decide I mean what we're seeing in Iraq
right now is a catastrophe of just in
the last week several stories coming out
of civilian massacres the Christian
Science Monitor looking at Balad and
Time magazine in this past week in this
past issue did a piece called one
morning in Haditha and that's a story
that actually is about a killing in
November when the US Marines were coming
through in a Humvee another roadside
bomb one of the Marines were killed and
so according to those in the village and
now according to a videotape that time
magazine got a hold of from an Iraqi
journalism student after the terrible
tragedy of the roadside bomb and the
killing of the marine
they raided homes in this residential
area it sounds like at least four of
them and they killed 15 civilians three
children seven women and the video
images are horrific to the extent that
now the Navy says that they're going to
open investigation at the time it was
reported as a one marine and 15 Iraqi
civilians died as a result of a roadside
bomb but that was far from the truth
apparently the people were killed when
the Marines went into the houses and
opened fire on them and balad a similar
situation and the Christian Science
Monitor reported this and talked about
how even other soldiers said this is
what will often happen after a roadside
bomb the military will just lay down
fire move into people's homes this is
not to put it mildly going to endear the
Iraqi population the civilian population
to this occupation and it just continues
and continues until the US troops pull
out in all of this Amy Goodman coming in
the backdrop of a debate that reached
front page news Tuesday morning Laura
Ingraham appearing on NBC's Today Show
question David Gregory NBC and some of
the mainstream media for not covering
the full story in Iraq the president
then referring to that in his news
conference and then Laura Ingraham
appearing on The O'Reilly Factor and
then using it for the rest of this week
this past week on her program what's
your take on either what she said or how
it played out this week there's not very
much good news coming out of a rock
right now but she says he's not getting
the full picture unfortunately it would
be a good thing if there was a lot of
good news coming out of Iraq I just
described two stories that came out this
week that dr. Laura cannot deny and
that's just two examples what is also of
grave concern is that the Pentagon is
now paying reporters and this is a story
that we've heard over the months
has cleared the Lincoln group which is a
company that was set up by a US military
man and a young student out of Britain
they got something like a hundred
million dollars to basically plant
stories in Iraqi papers now what are we
talking about here and the Pentagon
clearing them saying they didn't do
anything wrong I think what's true is
that the Lincoln group was doing the
Pentagon's bidding and they were
following the orders of the Pentagon
they were doing what they were paid to
do but this is a very serious problem
and I hope dr. Laura and all of the
media take this up is the planting of
these stories in the Iraqi media I think
the number at this point is something
like 1.6 billion dollars that we have
paid as US taxpayers that the US
government has paid to plant stories in
the Iraqi media I guess what you would
call good news stories the problem with
this is the Iraqi people on the ground
do not see the occupation as good news
and so they learn to distrust their
media with the Pentagon paying Iraqi
reporters paying reporters to take
stories that are written by the US
military now we wouldn't accept this in
this country and there are problems by
the way with this in this country we
know about Armstrong Williams getting
quarter of a million dollars but there's
outrage when people hear this and if the
u.s. is trying to model for other
countries the US shouldn't be doing it
to the people of Iraq if the only way
they can get good news stories out there
is by planting them you know there is a
very serious problem on the ground in
Iraq our guest is Amy Goodman our phone
lines are open the numbers will continue
to be on the bottom of your screen and
also our email address journalist c span
org are the democrats though voicing
credible alternatives will you raise a
very good point Steve no I mean you take
someone who is standing out from the
pack and that is Senator Russ Feingold
of Wisconsin he stood out before
remember he was the lone senator who
spoke out who voted against the
USA PATRIOT Act something that people
across the political spectrum in this
country are deeply concerned about I
really do think that lines are breaking
down conservative and liberal it's not
so easy to figure out where the protest
is coming from you can't say well
conservatives will support this and
progressives will not support this when
it comes to issues of corporate control
when it comes to issues of privacy I
think people are united in this country
and Senator Feingold opposed the USA
patriot act and most recently introduced
a resolution of censure against
President Bush there are grave
expressions of concern everything from
what is happening now in Iraq which is
being protested in the highest levels of
the Pentagon I mean Jack Murtha who was
no pacifist the Democratic Congress
member from Pennsylvania when he spoke
about the calamity that is Iraq many
said he was challenged channeling the
voices of the of the generals but it's
not just the war in Iraq it's also
spying at home and President Bush saying
that he has the right that the bush
administration has the right to do this
without warrants and this is of concern
to everyone I mean you have a new mexico
congress member heather wilson a
Republican who has challenged the
President on this and when he comes to
the American people I mean I think the
protest is even broader and yet when it
comes to censure senator Feingold could
we expected wouldn't get the Republican
senators but not to be able to get
Democratic senators to support them and
then of course when it comes to Iraq you
have the people that many Democrats have
been talking about and Republicans as a
frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination for president Hillary Rodham
Clinton of New York joseph Lieberman of
Connecticut they're not opposed to war
and this is what's deeply frustrating to
the American people is that
conservatives and progressives are
united more than half the people in this
country
and I daresay many many people in the
military as well are opposed to this
invasion but they don't see an
opposition party that is expressing
these views the Democrats are not
speaking out against war are not calling
for a withdrawal as you might imagine we
have a lot of people want to talk to Amy
Goodman our guest is a graduate of
Radcliffe she studied anthropology and
is an eighth of a beige or New York our
first call comes to us from lake wateree
south carolina good morning hi Steve hi
Amy hi it's great to talk to you wow
thanks for c-span and thank you so much
for democracy now what are we going to
do with the corporatization of the media
with the control that giant corporations
and big money have over the political
and military industrial complex here in
this country how in the world are people
going to unite in some kind of populist
movement to try to reverse these trends
that have been going on for so long now
the profiteering that has been going on
over this action Iraq is outrageous it
is tearing our country apart body and
soul it is bankrupting us and I just
feel so frustrated I just thank you so
much for your work with democracy down
pacifica radio and thank you so much for
c-span good to comment thanks thank you
well thanks so much for your comments I
think you are putting your finger on a
major issue of the day and that is that
we need an independent media in this
country that is not embedded I think
more powerful than any bomb than any
missile is the media the media are the
most powerful institutions on earth
they're the way we learn about the world
and they're the way the rest of the
world learns about us and it's very
frightening when we're projected to the
rest of the world through a corporate
lens the Pentagon has deployed the media
and we have to take it back
the embedding process that Victoria
Clark when she was spokesperson for the
Pentagon called a spectacular success
you know the process of putting
reporters in the front lines of troops
that gives you one perspective but we
also need reporters embedded in Iraqi
communities and hospitals in the peace
movement around the world to understand
the full implications of war because I
think if we had an accurate description
as well of what was happening on the
ground I don't think most people in this
country would stand for it and also it's
important to understand why people in
the rest of the world have such a
different image than people in this
country I wanted to contrast what we see
in Iraq and the kind of sanitizing of
the images whether it's a rocky civilian
casualties not actually seeing those or
US soldiers dead and dying you know
President Bush invoke that executive
order that says you can't film
photograph videotape flag-draped coffins
coming home of soldiers because he knows
the power of the images it's really the
power of the truth compare the coverage
of Iraq to what happened after Katrina
after the devastation in the Gulf
Network reporters raced down and the
side effect of President Bush not taking
action quickly you know what happened
that week course that hurricane hit on
Monday and the levees broke and
President Bush was being photographed
with a country music star and he went
back then to Crawford continuing the
longest presidential vacation and
history but he wasn't alone the shooter
the Vice President Dick Cheney was in
Wyoming he stayed there till Thursday he
said he did cut his vacation short but
he stayed till Thursday Condoleezza Rice
was here in New York taking in spamalot
shopping at a high-end shoe store I
think it was on Thursday and one of the
customers in the shoe store shouted what
are you doing here when people are
drowning in New Orleans and they took
her out that's they took out the
customer but here was the Bush
administration not responding to this
natural
rafi and the reporters were there on the
ground and we saw something very unusual
they were reporting from the victim's
perspective because they didn't have
troops to embed with because President
Bush hadn't sent them in and so here you
had all of America looking at their TV
screens seeing bodies floating by a
young woman reporter interviewing a man
who was holding his son saying his
wife's hand he had been holding it and
it just slipped away and she said take
care of the kids in the reporter started
to cry this is what unen bedded
reporting looks like you know I don't
like the photographs where they showed
white residents they were getting stuff
from stores and they said they were just
taking care of their family and you saw
black residents and they called them
looters sure there were looters and in
New Orleans but they were the
corporations that make a killing off the
killing in Iraq like the Halliburton's
doing the same in New Orleans so that
sort wasn't good any good but it was the
pictures that were unembarrassed
paragraph on the Bush presidency what
would you say what would your right
President Bush lies and the rest of the
world sees this because they don't have
the same kind of embedded media that we
do in this country or i would say
president bush lies and the corporate
media should stop acting as a megaphone
for these lies let's go to Gulf Shores
Alabama good morning good morning this
is very interesting this first of all
before I start I want to tell you that
the bush is God and for Amy Goodman more
profitably actually her name should be
Osama bin Amy Goodman I got some
important information for you Bush is
only going to be President Lin you don't
have to worry too much you only going to
be president for what two and a half
years maybe two years few months and
then he will just walk away and hand it
over to his brother so you don't have to
worry too long you'll be worried too
long you'll be gone in two and a half
years and then Jeb Bush is coming so you
had something else to write but let me
tell you
you said independent media I could not
agree with that statement more and media
is definitely more powerful than the
guns and Bill Clinton when he went to
Belgrade to bombed Belgrade city which
is the second time he was bombed since
the Nazis bomb that'll great he bombed
the television station over there I
don't know how many stories this is Lama
been good men did on that ICB headers
everywhere there are people being killed
just because this is something offense
just to say something offensive against
Islam they this guy who is going to be
killed in Afghanistan right now because
he's just dare to deviate from this
behaviour and he wants to be a Christian
I wonder how many stories this Osama bin
Goodman has done on that Thank You
caller any good uh well first of all
when the caller raised the question of
you know here you have bush and look at
Bill Clinton before him and how many
stories did we do on the US and NATO
forces bombing RTS that's a radio
television Serbia I think he makes a
good point there we did a lot of stories
on this that was a war crime and
President Clinton should be held
responsible for that the bombing of a
civilian outlet that was on April 22nd
1999 at the time I was at the an awards
dinner of the overseas press club I was
there with my colleague Jeremy Scahill
we were being honored among many other
reporters for doing a documentary on
Nigeria drilling and killing Chevron and
Chevron and Nigeria's oil dictatorship
looking at the chevron corporation in
this country and what it was doing in
the Niger Delta a crisis that continues
through to today but at that time that
was the moment
the military bombed RTS and when we went
back to the office we saw the body parts
of the media workers being pulled out
what had these people done to deserve
this fate I think we do have to have a
uniform standard of justice and my
criticism is by no means just against
the standing president of the United
States I don't think President Bush's
god I don't think most people believe
that we have a secular society and it is
very important that we separate church
and state that is what will protect
everyone of every different religion but
absolutely we have to look at the
sanctions that were waged against Iraq
put on Iraq for 12 years that weakened
that population the civilian population
I'm not talking about Saddam Hussein and
we have to look at the current
occupation and the invasion that led to
this montezuma New Mexico Democrats line
next caller for Amy Goodman good morning
good morning and thank you immensely for
democracy now I can get it on NPR but
I'm very worried about the media in
general the corporate media and I was
wondering if you could give us other
suggestions because radio is 24 7 in New
Mexico right wing hate radio and i can't
find other TV networks besides well
corporate media is there anywhere else
we can look besides NPR democracy now
and well i'm glad you raised that issue
i think the key is turning to a
diversity of sources that's what we need
to do and although there are hundreds of
channels in this country what matters is
who owns those channels and media
concentration is a great threat to a
Democratic Society just having a few
media moguls owning so many of the
channels we're down to a handful of
these owners democracy now broadcasts on
Pacifica Radio on NPR stations on public
access TV stations which are also under
great through
today on PBS stations and we're also on
both TV satellite networks on dish
network we're on Channel nine for 15
which is free speech TV which is an
independent 24-hour network we're on
channel 9 for 10 which is linked TV and
link is also under echt TV channel 375
these are independent channels that
bring you independent documentaries and
news low-power FM stations college and
community stations and together I think
it's very important that we open the
public media spaces I mean what's
happening right now in Congress with
various legislation is that the telecoms
the telecommunications companies and the
cable franchises the cable companies are
battling it out for control of even the
local airwaves but there's one thing
they agree on and that is trying to do
away with public access TV you know
public access TV is very important they
are the places in every community where
people can make their own media that's
not brought to you by commercial
sponsors not brought to you by well as
George gurbin ER he just recently died
great journalism ethicist and professor
at the University of Pennsylvania said
not brought to you by corporations that
have nothing to tell and everything to
sell that are raising our children today
we need these independent media spaces
and we have to preserve the ones that we
have you know the cable the cable
industry when they come into a town
because the community doesn't want the
roads to be dug up more than once one
cable company will get to dig up the
roads in a town and lay down the cable
and in exchange for that monopoly they
have to give back a few public interest
channels to the community now when they
renegotiate their franchises they're
trying to do away with those channels
and their media activists in every
community who are working on that and
when people find out they don't like it
it doesn't matter if you're Republican
Democrat independent they don't like the
idea of just a few media owners owning
the whole media landscape and I think
it's something we have to be more
involved with and more understand we do
lot on this issue and people who go to
our website at democracynow.org e and
that website is linked through c span
org tampa florida supporter of the
president good morning welcome to the
program oh yes sir how you doing today I
want to ask ask her a question about
when she talked about the uniform system
of justice she's talking about
international justice or justice here
back in the States I mean are we talking
about activist judges when I talk about
a uniform standard of justice I mean at
the state level of the federal level and
also internationally I really do think
we have a lot in common with people
around the world and that is people care
about law and order people care that if
someone is responsible for a killing
that they be brought to justice whether
it's a common criminal a murderer or
whether it's a head of state it is very
important that we uphold universal
standards of justice it's why the
International Criminal Court was
established now President Bush when he
came into office he immediately unsigned
the ICC treaty the International
Criminal Court treaty I mean President
Clinton didn't do much better he signed
on the last day he possibly could but
then President Bush unsigned it and he
was quite clear about why he said we you
know it's fine for them in other
countries but we're not going to hold US
soldiers and US officials to the same
standards well that's simply
unacceptable and then the Bush
administration went a step further and
they started to negotiate with countries
to negotiate these bilateral agreements
that said we will not give you military
aid to your country if you hold the US
if you say that the US has to abide by
the International Criminal Court where
they couldn't pick up a US official or a
US soldier and try them in the ICC now
that has come back to hurt the Bush
administration and recently the
Secretary of State Condoleezza Rice was
at the inauguration of a remarkable
woman Michelle Bachelet who has just
become the first woman president of
chilly everyone should know her story
this is a woman who was a political
prisoner who was tortured herself as was
her mother underpin of [ __ ] that's the
dictator of Chile for 17 years came to
power in 1973 on a number another
September 11th September 11 1973 he was
supported by President Nixon he was
supported by Henry Kissinger he was
supported by itt the corporation and he
rose to power killing thousands of
Chileans Michelle Bachelet and her
mother were imprisoned and tortured her
father was a general he was imprisoned
tortured and died in prison a michelle
bachelet is now the president of chile
and the person that she has appointed to
be one of the deputy heads of the
military was her father's cell mate and
when he went into exile he went to
Nicaraguan was one of the heads of the
sandanista military it's a very
interesting development well Condoleezza
Rice was there and something very
interesting came up the US has cut off
military aid to many Latin American
countries because they will not sign
this agreement that they won't hold us
officials and soldiers accountable to
these universal standards of justice and
now the Pentagon is very concerned about
this because that it is interrupting
their military relationships with these
Latin American armies and so there is a
now and issue being raised where the
Bush administration is backing off and
saying okay maybe we won't make you sign
these agreements I would argue that
maybe that's why Latin America is in one
country after another turning in a
different direction perhaps because they
don't have these very close alliances
their armies being shored up by the
Pentagon maybe that's a good thing a
couple of emails you refer to earlier to
Laura Ingraham who did broadcast her
program from Iraq in February and used
the audio in a couple of interviews over
the last month and this question from
Nancy moody a point Texas one was Amy
Goodman last in Iraq um I was not in
Iraq we do a daily national grassroots
global news hour but we turn to
reporters and correspondents in Iraq oh
all the time most recently this past
week we were talking with the Christian
Science Monitor reporter who broke the
balad story of the killing of Iraqi
civilians and I think it's very
important to bring out the stories of
those on the ground and I also think
it's very important to talk to US
soldiers they can tell you a great deal
about what's happening as we speak now
March is being finished up that went
from Tijuana to San Francisco and it's
led by two people who are deeply
connected to Iraq one is Fernando Suarez
the sole are he lost a son hay-soos one
of the first US Marines to die in Iraq
he is latino also Pablo Paredes another
Latino officer another Latino military
man in the military who actually signed
up himself and he refused to deploy to
Iraq he said he didn't think that was a
way to protect the security of this
country and he Fiat refused to get on
the ship he was court-martialed and they
are leading a march of Latinos across
the state of California a 241 mile march
to raise issues of the US military and
the way people these soldiers on the
front line have been put in harm's way
and also really put the world in harm's
way decreasing the security of this
country for the false reasons that the
Bush administration put forward that
there were weapons of mass destruction
when in fact there were not and I think
we should listen to these voices people
like Camilla Mejia who served in Iraq a
Florida National Guardsmen came back to
this country and filed for conscientious
objector status said what we were doing
there was not what he learned was the
honorable thing to do said he didn't
want to participate in the torture in
the mist behavior that he saw too many
of those he worked with engaged in he
was deployed to detention facilities and
not just at Abu Ghraib he off
to testify before Congress and instead
of being invited to speak before
Congress he was court-martialed and
served almost a year in prison these are
people who have deep moral conscience
a--'s who wanted to serve their country
that's why they signed up but that said
they said that this was not improving
the national security of the United
States our conversation on this Sunday
morning is with Amy Goodman host of
democracy now on Pacifica Radio she is
joining us from our studios at Pace
University in midtown Manhattan next
call is from Rockville Maryland good
morning I want to thank you very much uh
this good but not want to thank you for
your efforts efforts in exposing uh the
cruelty of the American
military-industrial complex and the
promotion of global corporate fascism
but also but I want to ask the host of
question if I may before I ask you one
why don't you utilize American Free
Press instead of relying on the
controlled corporate media that's a
local paper out of DC in the Michael
Collins Piper and others have some very
good issues in their newspaper so if you
could have appreciated to get utilize
American Free Press and maybe have alex
jones as a guest on there one time to
from infowars.com but i want ask Miss
Goodman um uh why you claim to be
alternative media and you to expose some
good things but you're missing I think
one of the biggest stories of the
century that is a government complicity
911 Alex Jones recently came out on CNN
on one of their programs uh about how
our government was behind 911 and may I
recommend two videos are loose change
loose change calm and 911 in plain sight
PLA any site and get both of those at
the power hour com I think those two
videos alone exposed that our government
was behind 911 okay let me stop you
there on the first point dealing with
the media let me also follow up in the
Goodman with a related to email and then
to get your response this is from a
viewer by the name of Tony in Iowa he
says why do you think the mainstream
media refuses to air topics that your
show covers and has democracy now
received
pressure not to air any certain subjects
no we have not gotten that kind of
pressure and we just continue to do our
work and with the support of listeners
and viewers around the country i mean i
think that's the best protection people
who are hungry for alternative
information again it doesn't matter
people's alternative view people's
political views I think people want
independent information to make their
own decisions and you know I think that
President Bush not finding weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq exposed more
than the president and the Bush
administration it exposed a media that
simply acted as a conveyor belt for the
lies of the administration I don't think
most people would have believed if
President Bush sat with a megaphone on
the steps the White House and said WMD
WMD but he had something so much more
powerful and that was the corporate
media in this country kept repeating
these allegations even though there was
descent to the highest levels of the
military dissent within the highest
levels of the intelligence community in
this country and we had people like
David Albright who is a UN weapons
inspector the times is so guilty of this
on their front pages repeatedly over and
over Judith Miller and Michael Gordon
writing those front page pieces remember
September eighth two thousand to a key
point when the bush administration was
pushing for war when President Bush had
just had a press conference at the at
Camp David with Tony Blair the British
Prime Minister saying the IAEA had just
come out with a new report indicating
that Saddam Hussein that nuclear weapons
were right on the horizon the IAEA had
not come out with any such report yet
few media outlets talked about that that
this was simply a lie instead that
weekend the New York Times had a
front-page story saying that Saddam
Hussein was getting aluminum tubes and
that showed that he was getting nuclear
weapons in fact that wasn't true and
there were UN weapons inspectors that
were saying that in fact David Albright
the UN weapons inspector had called
Judith Miller and spoken to her early
into the morning hours saying the
is not the case and yet the New York
Times iced out that dissent so people
were led to believe that there was
consensus when there was not consensus
and we have to challenge that it is very
important today to get that full
diversity of opinion at democracy now we
seek out that opinion whether inside the
establishment or outside because in fact
even then many people spoke out and we
have to make sure that there is a model
of an honest media in this country that
isn't simply used as part of the Arsenal
as the Pentagon but separate from that
we are not in a comfortable position
we're not there to cozy up to those in
power we're there to be the exception to
the rulers were there to hold those in
power accountable and on 911 yes there
has to be a full investigation done and
the so-called independent 911 Commission
did not come up who did not do a
satisfactory investigation Houston Texas
good morning yeah hello yes go ahead
call her yes I want to know how that
lady can sit there on TV and call our
president a liar she has no idea what
she's talking about she's not involved
with the intelligence II she doesn't
know but why don't you talk about the
French planes they found there why don't
you talk about the Russians why don't
you talk to real truth instead of
sitting there making up lies herself and
telling the American public that she
just should be embarrassed to be sitting
in that chair right now I'm ashamed to
be watching his TV right now I've sit
here and listen to you and want you to
show numerous times and all you do is
just put down this president you and the
media and all the other people your
facts are not straight you don't know
the truth and then you sit there and
call somebody a lot how can you do that
you ought to be ashamed of yourself or
even set in that chair right now as all
i have to say i'm tired of listening to
you by thank you amy goodman we also
have an email from michael Galvin who
says congratulations on your multiple
references to Laura Ingraham as dr.
laura suggesting due to your apparent
ability to convey any suggestion that
you were sarcastic or facetiously
labeling her such that you are clueless
beyond measure in differentiating her
from laura schlessinger
all I'll say is that the person that you
were referring to this week who went on
o'reilly and who is questioned on NBC
this is the person who should raise some
very serious questions about stories
being planted in the Iraqi media which
is an insult to the people of Iraq and
to the Arab world and insult to people
here in fact the US has been doing that
here for quite a while and we have to
investigate that as well the paying off
of journalists to to present a certain
side I think we have to trust in this
country and people have to trust outside
this country that the press is
independent in any response to the
collars points well that would be my
answer to that okay cookeville tennessee
is next for any good in good morning
good morning folks um yeah uh mrs.
Goodwin I've been a little bit of a
research on the pacifica radio wasn't
that started back during world war two
as a pacifist operation to keep our
troops from fighting during uh oh but
when the Soviet Union was invaded by
Hitler it seemed like he kind of changed
around a little bit and I noticed that
it seems like a lot of the people on
your show or pro Marxist and would that
be any reason why is it so
anti-capitalist thank you um well let me
talk a little about the beginning of
Pacifica Radio it was founded after
World War two in 1949 in berkeley
california founded by men named Lou Hill
who refused to fight in World War two he
was a conscientious objector and when he
came out of the camps he said there has
to be a media outlet that has run not by
corporations that profit from war but
run by journalists and artists and that
was the beginning of Pacifica the first
station kpfa it grew to five stations
kpfk in Los Angeles k pft in houston WPF
w in washington DC and WBAI here in new
york and it was the network that
pioneered the idea
of listener support where instead of
turning to corporations for support
turning to the listener and simply
saying please if you support not
everything you hear on the radio but if
you support a forum for free speech for
a rigorous discussion of ideas please
support this network and well it's here
55 years later and the philosophy of
listener and viewer support was adopted
by NPR and PBS as well now those
networks also take corporate
underwriting but Pacifica has refused to
take corporate underwriting next call
Seattle Washington good morning hello
yes good morning caller hi um yes I'm
just calling because I believe that
going into Iraq was a good decision for
our country um I you said it's not a
good decision first of all what would
you say about the mass graves that have
been found there and how Saddam
Hussein's regime has killed human rights
organizations say that maybe possibly a
million people he has killed with all
types and weapons including weapons of
mass destructions we've uncovered these
mass graves since we've been there so if
that's not a good regime to take down I
don't know what is and also if our
president lied about weapons of mass
destruction as you and a lot of
Democrats say that's not true either
because even most multiple intelligence
agencies around the world believe she
did have weapons of mass destruction
including some of his own high-ranking
officers Thank You caller Amy Goodman
well um there's no one I do not question
that Saddam Hussein was a tyrant no
question about that who killed many
Iraqis unfortunately for a number of
those years he was supported by the
United
dates and I think that probably made it
harder for the Iraqi people to take him
out but when you raise the question you
say that you're for the war and there
are reasons to have tried to get rid of
Saddam Hussein you're certainly entitled
to your opinion but I think what matters
is that the President of the United
States should give us the reason that he
is going into Iraq and he did he said we
are going in not because Saddam Hussein
is a human rights abuser which which he
is you know they tested a lot of these
reasons and they found that the American
people would not buy them would not
accept them as reasons to go in and
invade this country but they came up
with one reason that did sell that did
frighten the American people and that
was weapons of mass destruction and that
was the reason that was given and that
turned out not to be true and that's
very important point that if President
Bush said we are moving into Iraq we're
going to invade Iraq because Saddam
Hussein is a human rights abuser well he
is and if that's the reason he gave and
then he was telling the truth but he
didn't because he knew the American
people would not support that reason for
invading Katrina vanhu mass destruction
was a lie Katrina vanden Heuvel who is
the editor and publisher of the Nation
magazine has in the washington post
today this piece called had it with
Hitler here is a modest proposal for
improving national political discussion
stop equating our opponents with famous
dictators their chief executioner's
police apparatus or ideologies and this
cuts across the political spectrum two
examples on the Republican side senator
Rick Santorum who back in May of 2005
protesting Democrats in their opposition
to the nuclear option it's the
equivalent of Adolf Hitler in 1942
saying I'm in Paris how dare you invade
me how dare you bomb my city it's mine
or on the Democratic side entertainer
Harry Belafonte who said we've come to
this dark time in which the new Gestapo
of Homeland Security lurks here where
citizens are having their rights
suspended your reaction um yeah
the whole issue of Hitler being used to
demonize opponents as a problem but i
also think having just interviewed Harry
Belafonte last Saturday night that it's
very important to point out what is
happening here at home what is happening
with the crackdown on peace activists
and this is something that I think
frightens everyone when you have a Peace
Center in Pittsburgh the Thomas Merton
Peace Center where it turns out that the
FBI has been infiltrating monitoring
them when you have Quakers in Dade
County Florida who have open meetings
encourage people to come out if they
have a protest they let people know in
the paper and then they learn that
they're on a Pentagon watch list I think
this inspires fear in people and this is
not healthy for a Democratic Society it
was actually NBC that exposed this
Pentagon watchlist group after group
that raises questions about Bush
administration policy being followed by
the Pentagon this is of grave cause for
concern today we have to feel that
dissent is healthy and I think that's
the role of the media is to make dissent
commonplace in this country to make
people not afraid to speak that's what
make will make this country healthy
let's conclude with this last email from
Mike who says ask her if she wants to
win America or Iraq ask her if the
insurgents get a morale boost from her
bashing our president and by focusing on
the one percent of the troops who are
against the war I think the people of
America the people of Iraq the people of
the world win when the US troops
withdraw from Iraq our guest Amy Goodman
who is joining us from New York the host
of democracy now and on Pacifica Radio
heard in how many stations around the
country we broadcast on over 400
stations radio and television stations
around the country and also we video and
audio podcasts and our
transcripts are available democracy now
you are gee thanks as always for joining
us and thank you for taking calls